وبعد هذه التصريحات للرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين بدت ان المرحله مرحله
انكار او مقابره سيطره روسيه تتقلص
وتقابلها دعايه سياسيه واعلاميه لابقائها
متماسكه ظاهريا على الاقل التظاهر بان كل
شيء تحت السيطره في روسيا يزداد صعوبه
اكثر من اي وقت مضى وفقا لصحيفه
البريطانيه القياده الروسيه وبمزيج من
القمع والدعايه المتواصله حاولت ابقاء
جمهورها هادئا الى حد كبير لكن الشعب الذي
ظل حتى الامس القريب غائبا عن الصوره
لدغته الحرب فجاه بعد ان طالت مدتها موسكو
بارافاقياود وغيرها من المناطق الحدوديه
باتت في مرمى لاستهدافات بعضها بشكل شبه
يومي كما ان المعركه الان تقترب من
المواطنين الروس اكثر فاكثر خاصه مع تحول
مشهد الشاحنات العسكريه العابره في
الشوارع الى واقع معاش وقع مشحون عززه
اشخاص منتشرون بين المره بمحاولات يائسه
للتجميد واستدعاءات لكل من هو قادر على
حمل السلاح هذه الدعايه الروسيه وقعت
احيانا بفخ الصوره فالاخيره خذلت القائم
باعمال حاكم مقاطعه خرسون بلاديمير بعد
ساعات من انهيار السد كخوفكا ولم تؤتي
ثمارها حاول بعث جو من الحياه الطبيعيه
قائلا ان سكان نوبيا كافكا ومناطق اخرى
يسيرون بهدوء في الشوارع فيما بدت محطات
البنزين والمتاجر مفتوحه وكالمعتاد لكن
الصوره من خلفه وعبر النافذه يمكن من
خلالها رؤيه مياه الفيضانات تتصاعد بوضوح
في ساحه البلده التي غمرت ها المياه
بالفعل لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات